I got lucky I and I hate the word luck
but like I'm living through a time where
entrepreneurship is cool hmm in 1983
like Russell Simmons doesn't think like
that the CEO of IBM is the [ __ ] [ __ ]
yes ladies and gentlemen we are back
with a very very very very very special
guest I would I would argue to say your
favorite entrepreneurs favorite
entrepreneur Gary Vee thanks for having
me welcome and thanks Mary
I'm fired up one thing that you wrote
that I thought was really dope was or
said or something was uh everyone said
you were the wine guy until you weren't
yeah
what is everyone saying that you are now
I think a lot of not I think 50% of the
people in the world think I'm a
motivational speaker yeah I think I will
be one of the most respected like
entrepreneurs ever I'm not gonna make
the most money right
Elon Musk and sucks uh Bezos and Meg
Whitman there's there's tons of people
that are you know gonna do it bigger uh
what what I think I'm gonna do is give
back more to the game you know the
people that are really in the
billionaire girls boys club they're not
in the trenches like I am mm-hmm they're
not spitting [ __ ] he may flip tactics
they're not they're not doing podcasts
cuz they know they're gonna reach
different people they're not they're not
in it when you started this did you have
this grand plan or was it like this just
needs to be documented and this whole
thing kind of snowball Vayner was
finally in a place where I was ready to
make content again because in 2012 to 14
I was kind of head down do you rock hits
me up because I gonna make a film for
you I'm like you know what yeah cool
let's do it makes a film I really like
it I really like him he's a good kid I'm
like you know what I've been dying to do
this Q&A show so I hired d-roc full-time
we start a YouTube show called the
askgaryvee show and it starts popping a
little bit at the same token Casey and
others have the vlog thing go in first
person oh nice right yep and Dee rocks
like you have to do this you have this
I'm like dude I'm not [ __ ] walking
around with a camera in my hand and
somewhere somehow some moment I'm like
you should follow me around but then
finally back to not giving a [ __ ]
I was like I'm gonna be right and a lot
of people gonna do this in two years I'm
gonna get credit for starting a trend
then everybody's gonna do cuz it makes
sense it's a good idea yeah it's not
just a good idea for building your brand
and all that it's a good idea cuz it's
gonna be fun to look at when you're
[ __ ] old yeah I see non-business value
and vlogging I see personal family
heritage [ __ ] you know you can tell
there's a massive side of your life that
doesn't show my family family right do
you is it like you're working all day
but when the clock is up it's time to go
you wrap it up you go home and you're
just
well are there Gary no the weekends and
seven weeks vacation but Monday through
Friday yeah I'm getting home at 11:30 at
night there is no father so they just
know they're wait until the weekend yeah
we we're playing an extreme game at
least that's what it is now yeah it
works for me and my family working for
my wife's family so it's a little bit
more native to us I'm sure for some
people that's crazy yeah I respect that
everybody should do it their way and we
made a family decision that like you
know my wife and kids like we're gonna
keep that separate and and you know it's
already been hard because I'm getting
recognized so much more in public when
I'm with them but it's definitely it's
been very conscious and that doesn't
bother you like you're the one thing
that kills me or gets me is you're going
to everywhere you go you're doing
meetups you're doing like you it seems
like you genuinely love the energy the
connection that you don't get tired you
don't get worn out of like man I just
want to go to the mall with my family
and not be recognized um no I can't get
over the gratitude yeah like there's no
tired or annoyed or struggling with
something that that person doesn't know
about yeah that trumps the gratitude of
somebody being like holy [ __ ] you're
Gary Vee you bring you understand a very
important thing about me
my micro fame emerging fame comes not
because I'm [ __ ] hot not because I
can spit ours not because I can put a
ball in a hoop yeah my fame is coming
because I'm bringing people emotional
and mental value that then maybe maybe
they act on which then makes their life
better there is a different level of
relationship and it and I'm it's nice
how do you get to the billion-dollar
multi-billion dollar Jets owner I guess
what I'm saying how am i planning on
doing it what do you do with all take
that to that level i buy prince the
tennis racket business yeah I convert it
into a sneaker and hoodie brand I run it
through the Vayner and garyvee machine i
buy it for two hundred eight million
because now I'm building big businesses
I can afford it and I sell it for 2.7
billion to adidas cuz they need the more
contemporary brand I think that what I
did smart was I deployed self-awareness
eight years ago and said I have to build
a machine that's the scalable version of
me yeah so that when I buy smart water
on the decline or when I buy this [ __ ]
this thing that I will become the CEO of
so my executives have baynard's somebody
will become the CEO and then I will be
the CEO of a business that I buy for a
couple hundred million that I will sell
for two billion and I'll be off to the
races
you